for a generation of Star Wars fans the
original trilogy was the foundation for
which their fandom was born and raised
now as someone who was born after the
releases of episodes 4 5 & 6 I had the
opportunity to fall in love with the
galaxy far far away
through a different path Star Wars turns
40 this year but I think it's just a
good of time as any to celebrate what I
think is one of the most important video
game experiences of all time this is how
Knights of the older public made me a
Star Wars fan
[Music]
I remember my 13th birthday vividly
sitting in the kitchen of my mom's
apartment reading Greg Kasavin review of
Knights of the Old Republic on gamespot
on my stepdad all busted laptop hooked
up to some CRT monitor we salvaged my
brother kept hyping up this game and I
was thinking if I should ask for it as a
gift since it literally released that
day we didn't have much at the time so
we had to really think hard about the
games we bought and damn am I glad he
got it for me I always heard about Star
Wars knew about lightsabers and the Jedi
but not much else
I never immersed myself in that universe
until 92 The Old Republic not only was
it an incredible role-playing game from
Bioware rooted in D&D but it put me in
control of the Jedi Civil War 4,000
years ago I became part of the galaxy
living vicariously as this Jedi who
impacted the face of so many people in
the worlds around them I got to know
those who inhabited terrorists the
wealthy the gangs be impoverished well I
could have easily murdered anyone in my
path I chose to defend the defenseless
which is why I was shook when the SIS
destroyed the entire city and any
semblance of life rendering all my
efforts meaningless I had flashbacks of
terrorists when I first saw Alderaan
destroyed before lay his eyes moments
like these are what turn good people to
the dark side but I didn't grow
apathetic or let revenge consume me at
the Jedi Enclave on Dantooine I first
saw a narrative I could shape I learned
the Jedi Code from master Vande are my
very own Yoda there is no death berries
divorce I built my own lightsaber and
learn from and grew close to Bastila I
began to understand the force its power
and its fragility I put that to the test
when I had to decide the fate of Juhani
the Cathar Jedi on the brink of falling
to the dark side I thank you master Jedi
I will return special
I shall submit myself to their judgement
and hope you will forgive me player
agency permeated my trek across the
galaxy it's great that you could fully
embrace the dark side but I chose the
light the main objectives were always
the same find the star map to find and
destroy the star Forge but how I
accomplished this and the decisions I
made along the way are what captivated
me when I landed on Kashuk I knew I was
going to drive out the zurka corporation
for slaving wookies but who was I going
to help run things afterward solve our
got my back so I got his if you got to
know him and his family you could
understand what keep politics so the
first time I saw Chewbacca in the movies
it's as if I knew his ancestors and
understood the struggles that took place
on Kashuk well before his time stepping
onto the rough sands of Tatooine as my
own Jedi thousands of years before Luke
Skywalker I almost felt the heat of the
planets to sun's beating down on me when
I land on manaan I just stopped to look
around soak in the vastness of the ocean
and the tranquility of Auto City I
learned about the shiny cell cat folk
but also had to decide the future of
their environment but it wasn't until
Korriban a barren desolate planet that
it truly understood the dark side
undercover as a student at their academy
I saw their ways
savage ruthless but their will fickle as
I walk through the valley of the Dark
Lord's there stood monuments of the past
sit rulers
all this time I had a ragtag crew of
misfits unique in their own way
the comically violent droid HK 47 a
prideful and aggressive Mandalorian and
kandra's the scrappy twi'lek mission veo
the nagging ly virtuous cars and t3m for
a spiritual predecessor to r2d2 just the
name a few these are just a few of the
memories I have leaving my mark in
galactic history but nothing is more
burnt into my memory than the moments on
the Leviathan my relatively calm quest
for the star maps and the star Forge
reached a turning point and facing Darth
Malak for the first time many truths
were unveiled why did I have all these
visions of exactly where I needed to go
where all the star maps were why did I
share the seemingly curious yet strong
bond with past alone and why did I
become such a powerful Jedi in such a
short period of time there's one answer
I was Darth Revan
and in that moment my understanding of
who my character was why the story even
existed in the first place was a sort of
limbo now the game walked me back
through the trail of breadcrumbs they
left that hinted at my character's true
identity but I still had so many
unanswered questions it's regarded as
one of the greatest plot twists in
gaming history but it was hardly the end
of the story
Basque Allah sacrificed herself to hold
off Malik but it would come back to
haunt us as we crash-landed on the
unknown planet inhabited by the ancient
rocket aah
but just as she saved reven me from the
dark side I too had the chance to bring
her back your brave mister was a fool
but you were also right the dark side is
not totally consumed me I cannot raise
my blade against you everything led to
the Battle of the star Forge the
relentless war factory that it pump out
endless warships and crushed the
Republic but my bond with Vassalo was
strong enough she could turn her
all-powerful battle meditation against
the Sith and turned the tide then I
would finally square up with Malik one
on one and just as I saw later in the
movies the light prevailed but not
without tragic losses along the way and
in the end
as the darkness takes me
Knights of the Old Republic is a
magnificent game and a beautiful Star
Wars story but what I realize is that
despite having the choice between dark
and light the journey was anything but
black-and-white I went in without much
knowledge but I came out enraptured by
this universe my love for Knights of the
Old Republic made a seamless transition
to the franchise as a whole
I saw the Millennium Falcon and thought
of the ebon Hawk I heard yo to speak and
remembered the wise words of master van
der I saw the death star and was
reminded as a star Forge and so when I
watched Leia Organa and Luke Skywalker
lead a rebellion against the Empire in
the back of my mind was bachelor Shawn
and revin and the lives they led 4,000
years ago as Star Wars enters another
era and reaches a different generation a
new foundation is built for new fans
their first memories will probably be of
an older Luke han and Leia with rey and
finn taking the fight to kylo Ren and
that's just as valid as how I was
invested in being revin hopping from
planet to planet trying to leave my mark
across the galaxy and ultimately defeat
Darth Malak
and the Sith Empire Knights of the Old
Republic gave me Star Wars and the
excitement to be a fan of this franchise
it's something I'll always cherish
wherever you go you will be recognized
as the saviors of the galaxy the heroes
fire age
but you must remain ever-vigilant for
one day you may be called upon yet again
to defend the glory of the Republic
against the jeers guitar side is the
destiny of the Jedi
[Music]
I am only one of many who have a story
to tell so please share how you fell in
love with Star Wars in the comments
below and my friends and colleagues here
at GameSpot also have stories to tell so
please subscribe to our channel thanks
for watching
[Music]